you
all righty everybody time to gather our
thoughts and plant our feet so far we've
only done a very very few basic things
here so it might seem like we've only
just barely left the beach but the
reality is if we turn around we realize
we're actually in very deep waters
already and we are very far from the
beach let's consider the current
situation we actually already have a lot
of variables and these are going to need
to be accounted for not only do we have
explicit variables right we actually
have these implicit ones as well so our
explicit variables are a percent change
as pattern recognition so how are we
actually recognizing patterns what we've
used percent change and and this could
be obviously other things we could use a
logarithm to do something like this and
there's a whole lot of other things that
we could do to recognize patterns we've
just happened to have chosen percent
change for its simplicity
now next number two to dive deeper into
that percent change we've done start
point to end point percent change as
compared to point by point or and to
start percent change right so point by
point could possibly give us look
different looking patterns but the lines
themselves would be closer together
in theory anyways uh and then an end to
beginning percent change would give us
kind of the opposite of what we have
here right so if you look here we've got
very close starting points but as we get
to the very end we have very wide I mean
it's almost probably three times as
variable as the beginning so if we were
to reverse this in theory it would be
reversed and therefore the end of the
pattern would be more similar and it
could be argued that it was more likely
for the end to continue you know to be
more predictive or accurate in its
prediction than in this format but in my
at least in my opinion theoretically I
would argue that really they're the same
pattern the only difference is this one
has been this ones reacting quicker
right so I don't really think it makes a
huge difference but anyway it is
something on the table number three
we're using a fix
pattern length of 30 pieces of data that
could be we could do 31 we can do 20 we
could do 30,000 we know the same leg we
could do any number right and probably a
good number would be anything between
ten and a thousand really since we are
doing tick data here so keep that in
mind
so pattern length next we're using a
fixed value or weight of these patterns
no matter how old or fresh these
patterns are so if we're getting this
pattern we're comparing it to a pattern
that we actually found I mean in this
case we are only using one day's worth
of data but in most cases you would
probably looking be looking at years
worth of data and you would want to be
comparing your current data or your
current pattern and years worth of
patterns but would you value a pattern
from two years ago the same as you would
value a pattern from like a week ago you
know probably not but maybe but it is
something to put on the table and right
now we're validating them exactly the
same five we are looking 20 to 30 points
in the future to decide on the outcome
we're just averaging the outcome from 20
to 30 points in the future basically
enough time to X have executed a trade
and held it for a few seconds and then
maybe sold that trade so is this you
know 20 to 30 points in the future
truthful should we make it a wider range
we make it further in the future shorter
in the future all those things could be
switched up the next thing we have is
similarity required for the patterns to
be a quote unquote match as I showed you
you have a huge difference between 70%
accuracy required and 75% accurate
accuracy required and number six is
quite possibly one of the worst
variables to have because we could
require not only you know 71 72 73 we
could require 71 point 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 minima you could have a million
decimals you could have a trillion
decimals right so in this sense on
number six isn't on there isn't in its
lot can you say an infinite
number of possibilities for the number-6
so that one's the hardest one but
luckily there is an answer for machine
learning but moving on we have an
implicit variable that I haven't really
talked about too much yet but that
variable is opportunity versus accuracy
so usually in machine learning to
typically find the best scenario that we
can especially in the case where we
might have been literally an infinite
number of scenarios it's much like how a
company finds the best price for their
product so profit margin matters but the
amount sold matters as well right so a
very cheap price is going to sell a
bunch of units presumably but a profit
per unit sold will be much less than if
we had a higher price per unit but that
higher price per unit would result in
fewer sales so you've got to make this
nice balance right you've got a way
opportunity here which would be you know
the volume of possible trades much like
the amount of units sold compared to the
accuracy which is how often we're
actually correct with our prediction
which is more like profit margin since
you might you know even though that
might not sound like profit margin but
since you might have let's say 60%
accuracy and a very high volume of
opportunities compared to 80% accuracy
and low volume so then you've got a
percentage profit margin so consider
consider following if you found an
algorithm that will earn you $2 a trade
and it is 85% accurate very appealing
with this your allotted an opportunity
to deploy this tactic 600 times for 600
trades so that means you're going to at
85% you'd be successful with 510 of
those trades you would also lose 90 of
them so 510 successful trades at $2 a
trade is $1,000 and thousand and $20
sorry Skype anyway 90 unsuccessful
trades at $2 a trade means you've lost
$180 so your total profit in this
scenario is 840 dollars let's consider
another situation you still earn $2 a
trade if successful but we actually
we've dropped we're only 70% accurate
that said with that 70 percent accuracy
it's a loser algorithm and gives you way
more opportunity you get 1800 trades
this time so this means out of 1800
trades at 70% accuracy you get 1260
successful trades for two thousand five
hundred twenty dollars in profit
this also means five hundred and forty
trades are not profitable so you let you
lose one thousand eighty dollars but
your total profit in the end is 1440 now
compared to the old 840 that's much
better so the above example even though
it might sound like well that was a lot
more trades for you know such a small
movement and accuracy that wasn't really
an under exaggeration so you just saw in
the previous video how big of a change
the move from 70 to 75 made if we move
from 70 to 85 I could show you but we're
it's going to be will probably won't
even get we would this this chart
probably won't even show up right so so
that's um it is ads there's probably an
under exaggeration as far as opportunity
change also you lose comparable patterns
the patterns that are actually very
comparable on you lose them so not only
need lose opportunity I think you're
sacrificing accuracy as well at the same
time now that's a huge wrench to throw
into the equation because obviously we
have an infinite number of variables
right because again we could look we
could require something like seventy two
point five five two two five one two
five two five five one accuracy right
you it's just unlimited and you quickly
find that you've got like an unlimited
number of variables x another unlimited
number of very funds another endless so
where do you even start right so the
accepted method when it comes to machine
learning and you know navigating your
way through infinity is you continue
adjusting in the same direction
variables that are producing an
increasing performance
so as you tinker with a variable if in
performance is going up exponentially
you continue your tinkering with that
variable okay so um so that's how you do
it and then you would continue tinkering
until performance drops right and then
you know you've found a decent balance
point that said as time goes on it's
very likely for all these variables to
change all right so as volatility might
change the overall economy and whatever
you're going to notice that the
variables themselves in the perfect
balance is also changing so that's what
luck machine learning is for and this is
kind of the downside to the idea of a
neural network which is most closely
what we're doing here and that's that it
you know if you do a neural network a
huge neural network is the most accurate
of probably even support vector machines
but until you can do the computation of
that huge a neural network it's not the
best method but here at least for our
our needs so far everything that we've
done even though python is slow um it
can be done in like C with a decent
computer but we will talk on on that a
little bit more in depth in a future
video
anyway definitely required video I
realized we didn't do any any
programming but you have to be made
aware of where we stand at the moment as
far as you know what were what we're
doing and what this means what the
implications of what we're doing are and
all of the variables that are coming
into play already that a few of which
have unlimited variance to them so with
that I'm going to conclude the video 13
and in 14 we'll continue back on with
programming and having a lot more fun
and creating even more variables so
anyways as always thanks for watching
thanks for the support in the
subscriptions and until next time